mr. president it's good to see you thank
you today the tax plan announced and
it's interesting you're getting you're
getting hit from the left and some on
the right
LeBron Paul's gonna vote for it I think
but he said it's not significant because
the upper income tier doesn't get a lot
of tax rate relief or any and then Ron
Wyden calls it basically a middle-class
con job it's not really a tax cut for
the middle class so left and right well
they're big tax cuts the biggest cuts in
the history of our country actually we
have reformed we have simplification and
honestly I'm surprised a little bit to
hear what you're saying because we've
really gotten great reviews people are
loving it even a certain newspaper that
I don't like very much came out today
and they gave humor for four Pinocchios
and they said because he was not telling
the truth when it came to the middle
class because he said it's for the rich
and it's really not for the rich it's
for the middle class and it's for jobs
and I would say maybe even in that order
so the middle class is a big beneficiary
jobs and companies are big beneficiaries
but the companies really create the jobs
and we really have Laura we've had
tremendous receptivity to it to a point
that I don't think I've ever seen
anything quite like it so and I do think
Rand Paul by the way who I like I think
he's gonna vote for it Hillary Clinton
said last night that paying for the
dossier she defended it basically is
that it's different from meeting with
Russians like meeting with Russians he's
trying to make it make it make a
comparison between no totally defend it
well she talked about Oppo research is
wonderful Oppo research and it's but not
when it comes to us okay
Oppo research for us of course is no
good no that dossier which is totally
fake and made-up it's like a novel but
that dossier is a disgrace and it should
not have been allowed to be used and
then I hear the kind of money they spent
nine million I mean it's inconceivable
it's absolutely inconceivable it's
Arabic so we don't know
authorized payment we don't really well
they're trying to find out and we'll
find out but they really I think it's a
disgrace that a thing like that can take
place Donna Brazile in her new book
writes about the DNC Democrat primary
rigging and talks about corruption
internal corruption and unethical
finances and she tags Hillary Clinton
are you surprised about that everyone
you said about Bernie Sanders being fake
being being given the short shrift
I think it's an image you know like it's
a major story now I don't know if the
mainstream fake commedia because they
are fake and phony but I just don't know
if they're gonna pick it up but I want
to tell you that is a big story what you
saying it's illegal number one and it's
really very unfair to Bernie Sanders I'm
not a Bernie Sanders fan although I must
say I got a lot of his votes when he was
thrown out many of those people voted
for me because of trade because I agreed
with him and trade we're just doing more
about it than he can do and we're doing
a lot about it but that was I thought
that was terrible the justice system a
joke in a laughingstock you said the
other day what we well when I look at
immigration and I look at this whole
thing coming in by lottery and then we
can't do anything about it quickly and I
look at what's going on with justice
when it comes to so many different
topics I remember nothing
a lot of justice this guy would be tied
up forever in the court system you look
at some of the cases that are going on
forever and you have them dead to right
know the justice system has to go
quicker and it has to be really stronger
and fairer probably has to be fairer to
but it's very sad when you look at a
lottery system and you have people
coming into the country through the form
of a lottery and you know the country is
just so you understand the countries
aren't putting their finest in there
they're not putting their best and their
greatest and their finest in there and
this kid came in through a lottery
system that's going to end and it's
going to end fast in fact I've already
instructed Congress they must end it and
I think we're gonna get even Democrat
support on this you had a docket talks
today for the dreamers and your base and
what you campaigned on was real
common-sense policies you talked about a
verified building the wall chain
migration which is
huge all those things are happening part
of any daca deal so if the Democrats
want dreamer help they're gonna have to
do yeah we're gonna have to do a
verified chain migration sure chain
migration is one of the most important
things that most people is that a
requirement for you till yesterday most
people never heard of chain migration I
gave a form of a press conference and I
started talking about chain migration
and this horrible animal he's an animal
as far as I'm concerned 23 people have
touched him maybe came in because he was
in and he was only in with a green card
supposedly but chain migration where his
whole family comes and his mother can
come in his father his grandmother
everybody comes in chain migration is a
disaster for this country and it's going
to end now I've been talking about it
for a while but I think the public until
yesterday probably never heard about
chain right the Republicans didn't want
to touch it for a long time you have the
pressure to what the Republicans want to
touch it now it's become a very very
strong point right well it'd be part of
a dreamer deal that's a deal it'll be
part of a dock a deal there's a lot
different than dream I mean for the
deferred action for childhood arrivals
will will you require that if any
amnesty talks will will require chain
migration I don't think any Republican
would vote for anything having to do
with leaving chain migration chain
migration is a disaster for this country
and it's horrible I mean just take a
look at them 23 people potentially 22
verified its what I heard it's what I
gave whether it's 23 or whether it's 2
as far as I'm concerned to make
difference ok no no I know that but I
hear it's 23 it's a lot of people the
wall and I was at rallies that's what
people like they want that well so one
of the things but we're gonna have a
wall but in fact abuse at 1.4 billion he
would he would start and perhaps that
number has been Friday's one that's a
pittance phase one during the foot well
first of all they say the walls gonna
cost 40 billion it's not going to cost
anywhere near that Democrats are saying
we're talking about less than half also
you don't have a wall if two thousand
miles you have a mountain
you have rivers you have things that you
don't put the wall and you don't need
them never was planned for that no I
think for 18 billion dollars or less
we're going to have a great wall we're
doing prototypes right now we're gonna
make the choice we have the people from
border patrol and ice working with us
very closely because ultimately they're
the ones that are going to have to use
it one of the things that's come up
pretty strongly as we want to have
vision through the wall because you want
to see what's on the other side of the
wall you know you think we're going to
build a nice simple concrete wall but
it's not that simple no we're having the
wall we have to have the well we need
the wall for an other reason drugs drugs
are pouring into our country a lot of
them are coming in through the southern
border and the wall will be a tremendous
tool to help facilitate the ending of
the drugs coming in know that the wall
is actually coming along pretty well
that will also be a part of dhaka or
whatever it's a down payment or a
guaranteed funding well look when we get
the down payment we're gonna have a
guarantee believe me we're not taking a
down payment and then say where's the
rest I can miss cameras because you know
you don't spend all the money
immediately so we can put it back but
when we take it down payment I'm gonna
say I want to make sure the rest of the
money is calm you're heading off to age
a huge trip yeah lots of stakes you got
North Korea deal with the Chinese you're
gonna stop in Seoul your State
Department still has some unfilled
positions are you worried that the State
Department doesn't have enough Donald
Trump nominees in there to push your
vision through because other state
departments including Reagan's at times
undermined his agenda and there there's
a concern that the State Department
currently is undermining your agenda so
we don't need all the people that they
want you know don't forget I'm a
business person and I tell my people
well you don't need to fill slots don't
fill them but we have some people that
I'm not happy with there let me tell you
the one that matters is me I'm the only
one that matters because when it comes
to it that's what the policy is going to
be you've seen that you've seen it
strongly we're filling up roles and
don't forget Schumer and the Democrats
are just obstructing you can't get
anything through we have almost about
half the number of people coming through
as Obama had but in addition to that we
don't need
all of the people you know it's called
cost saving you know the old in the old
way you want your vision but I want my
vision but my vision is my vision anyway
it's called cost saving there's nothing
wrong with cost saving rex is in there
working hard he's doing his best he's
doing the best being with you for the
duration well we'll see I don't know
who's gonna be duration I think the
duration I tell you this I don't think
any president in nine months has done
the job that we've done and that
includes bills being passed by Congress
you look at what's passed by the Senate
by the house I think we're close to 70
bills maybe over 70 bills it's almost a
record you look at all of the
deregulation you look at Supreme Court
justice Gorsuch you look at all of the
other district judges federal district
judges and Court of Appeals judges
I don't think and then of course they
could be economy look at the economy
people are you getting the credit for
this economic revival without your tax
cut
yep through without Obamacare repeal yet
and this is a stunning economic revival
in 10-man one of the greatest in the
history of our country and I'm in here
now ten months and we are setting record
after record day after day I think we
hit another one today no I'm not getting
enough credit for it because a lot of
the reason is enthusiasm level business
level and also the fact that I've cut
regulations to the extent that I've got
them I mean I could tell you jobs that
we're never going to get built are now
being built take a look at the pipelines
the Keystone pipeline the Dakota access
pipeline man every day we're hitting new
highs very important GDP you take a look
GDP 3.2 to quarter now three and the
last one was after four or five really
obviously horrible hurricanes and that's
the equivalent of a point so that would
have been a four a four was unthinkable
and each time we go up a point that's
two and a half trillion dollars and
thousands I mean millions of jobs
actually the thing I'm most proud about
companies are starting to come back into
our country they were repatriating they
are coming back home and one of the
things about our taxes you talk about
repatriation we're bringing in probably
I think the number is going to be over
four trillion dollars coming back into
our
enforcement on this trip to China
intellectual property theft the
subsidies dumping in our country yeah
are you are you gonna be tough on the
enforcement side
given what they're doing to this country
you have to understand something very
important we have a problem called North
Korea are you gonna tie your D linked it
with with Korea with South Koreans trade
that we're gonna see but we have one
problem that's a very big problem is
called North Korea China has been
helpful we are talking trade with China
but I am also you know you have and
President Xi has been pretty terrific
most people have been saying you know
whether it's cutting the banking system
off from North Korea whether it's
cutting the oil down to North Korea
cutting supplies down and I must tell
you North Korea is a thing that I think
we will solve and if we don't solve it
it's not going to be very pleasant for
them it's not going to be very pleasant
so I guess for anybody but China is
helping us
Japan's worried there were no of course
they were they should be worried you
know they're very close to North Korea
they want a nuclear pledge from the
United a pan is a warrior nation now and
I tell China and I tell everyone else
that listens I mean you're gonna have
yourself a big problem with Japan pretty
soon if you allow this to continue with
North Korea you're gonna make any
pledges to Japan to defend them look
you're an ally they're an ally the Prime
Minister is a very good friend of mine
Prime Minister Robbie I become very
close I become very very close to
President Xi of China I think a lot of
good things are gonna happen I think
it's a very important trip I think this
is one of the more important trips that
our president is I'm like traveling now
right you're not a big but I think it's
important I'm going to China I'm going
to Japan South Korea I'm then going to
Vietnam where we have a tremendous trade
conference trade and we're starting to
do well in trade look NAFTA is a
disaster NAFTA is killing us on where we
negotiate we may have a meeting with
Putin we met and again Putin is very
important because they can help us with
North Area they can help us with Syria
we have to talk about Ukraine are you
having fun in this job I guess is it I
love it
well there's been a lot of false
reporting that I'm angry about things I
never
sinuan 14 I think the press is fake a
lot of the media is fake but so you
could say there's a certain anger there
but it's not really anger it's really
amazement how dishonest you know when
you get right down how dishonest the
news is but your families that I am I am
really well I think my family has been
treated unfairly I think that Ivanka has
been treated very unfairly frankly
Melania is really just powering through
it she's been incredible people loved
Ivanka people loved Melania and you know
they go through it but I do think the
family's been treated a little bit
unfairly in the end what is very nice is
we really have I don't think I'm saying
this in a braggadocious way I don't
think over a period of 9 or 10 months
there's been any president in the
beginning of their presidency that's
done anywhere close when you think about
regulations and Supreme Court and so
many different things things and stock
markets and the economy I like the fact
that you're impatient for change in a
city that is slow-moving and it moves at
a glacial pace and that's something you
got from the business as well and the
most you're impatient and the most
important thing that we're going to be
doing is tax cuts tax cuts if we get
this through and I think we will you're
gonna see this economy take off like a
rocket ship thank you so much thank you
very much Christina thank you thank you